so I'm going to start with this guy this
is Antoine de saint-exupéry please
excuse my French
he was an aviator at a time when we
called pilots aviators when aviation was
really dangerous
aviation was really dangerous because
the planes would crash and in his career
as an aviator he experienced several
crashes and survived almost all of them
he is once trying to set a speed record
from Paris to Saigon but his plane
failed and he crashed him the sahara
desert just outside of Cairo and he was
not prepared for desert survival so he
suffered terrible dehydration he
dehydrated so much that he stopped
sweating which is a really dangerous
thing to do in a desert and he suffered
horrible hallucinations fortunately he
was rescued by someone who knew how to
treat severe dehydration and he survived
and he recovered then World War 2 starts
he's exiled to America where he becomes
a writer and it turns out he's a really
good writer he is best remembered for
having written a children's book called
the little prince it's about an aviator
who is stranded in the desert who is
visited by a strange little boy who
lives on an asteroid and his suicidal
like most of the great children's books
it's not really a children's book but
it's it's really really good he wrote
other books of more grown-up kinds of
books and one of them contained one of
the best sentences ever written he said
it seems that perfection is attained not
when there is nothing more to add but
when there is nothing more to take away
it's just a brilliant sentence I've seen
it copied and quoted all over the place
it's used in talking about design and
architecture anything that combines
creativity and discipline he was talking
about the design of airplanes but it
seems to talk about everything and I
think it's particularly important in
thinking about computer programming
because we have a special relationship
with perfection our trade requires more
perfection than anything else or
programs have to be perfect or they fail
so he gives us some insight into how
perfection is obtained it's not obtained
by adding things it's attained by
subtracting things by removing things by
simplifying things and I think we can
apply that to the design of programming
languages as well which leads to the
principle of the good parts the good
parts idea is that if a feature is
sometimes useful and sometimes dangerous
and if there is a better option than
always use the better option it
surprises me that this is still
considered controversial
it seems to me that this is obviously
true but there are a lot of people who
complain you can't force me to use the
better option it's like why are we
arguing about this and I think it's due
to a fundamental misunderstanding of
what it is that we're supposed to do we
are not paid to use every feature of the
language at the end of the project there
isn't a manager with a clipboard who
says did you use plus plus did you use a
with statement did use comma as an
operator did you leave out any
semicolons excellent know that nobody
cares about that we are paid to write
programs that work well and are free of
error that's what we're supposed to be
doing now free of error when did that
become part of the deal well it turns
out it it has always been part of the
deal it's the most important part of the
deal but we do it so rarely that it's
easy to forget that that's the really
important part so I recommend everybody
learn as many programming languages as
you can because a good programming
language will teach you it'll change the
way you think about things and you can
use that improved model of thinking in
other languages as well so you know a
good language will teach you in the
language which has taught me the most in
my career has been Java Script which
really surprised me because the first
time I saw JavaScript I thought it was
the stupidest thing I'd ever seen
and so I be I made every mistake that
you can make in JavaScript starting with
the first one the worst one I didn't
bother to learn the language before I
started writing in it because if I
thought I understood what it did and I
also thought that there was so much
wrong with it I didn't want to damage my
brain by being aware of how it worked
and that turned out to be a really
foolish thing to do and JavaScript
punished me severely for that and then
continued to punish me until finally I
just to try to learn the language and
once I learned the language suddenly I
had this epiphany that this language was
not at all what I thought and as I
started learning it made me smarter
about how to be a programmer one thing
that concerned me about JavaScript
though is that it contains a lot of
design errors because the thing was
designed and implemented in ten days and
it turns out you can make a lot of
mistakes in 10 days and those mistakes
are still preserved in the standard of
the language and so you need to be aware
of that and work around it so I
developed a program called jeaious lint
which I wrote in JavaScript which reads
my JavaScript programs and tells me when
I'm using the features of JavaScript
which are more likely to create errors
and JavaScript is also instructive about
programming style when I started it I
had no intention of of trying to enforce
a programming style because my idea is a
programming style at the time were
completely wrong over the years
JavaScript or jeaious lint taught me to
be much smarter about that that there
are certain ways of writing programs
which are more likely to cause errors or
more likely to hide errors and so if you
can avoid doing that stuff and your
programs are better that the mistakes
tend to stand out and it's easier to get
things right so I wrote my own book
about my adventures with JavaScript and
J's Linton and what I learned on that
journey and it's called Java the good
parts and it's still in print and it
still sells well which is surprising for
a software book to be sold ten years
later most software books are obsolete
the time that they're printed so this
one is still relevant because what I
recognize as being good parts in
JavaScript turns out still are good
parts in JavaScript even so there are
lots of arguments against using the good
parts and I think it'd be a good time to
review some of those arguments the first
one is it's just a matter of opinion
that you know you say something's good
I say something's good we you know we
don't have to agree that all opinions
are equally valid and that turns out not
to be true so I am the maintainer of
jazz lint so I get reports from people
all over the world and it doesn't happen
very often but occasionally someone will
write to me and say we just had this
terrible bug and we spent two weeks
chasing it down and with some weird
coroner case in JavaScript that nobody
recognized and we lost a lot of time and
a lot of money on this and could you
please put a warning into jslint so that
you know this doesn't happen again so I
look at their report and if it makes
sense I'll incorporate it into jslint so
if you're using jslint
it means that that will never happen to
you that is not an opinion that is a
fact every feature is an essential tool
and I need to have access to every
possible tool in order to do my work it
turns out that's not true that there's
some tools that just don't work very
well and there's a small set of tools
which work really well and those are the
ones you should be using so if you can
produce better programs by using a
subset of the tools than the tools that
are unnecessary or not essential but a
tool is sometimes useful and this sounds
like a good argument you know I should
be able to use something if it's
sometimes useful but it turns out this
isn't actually an argument
everything is sometimes useful we are
really good at finding uses of things
and there is nothing so damaged so vile
so toxic so disgusting that we cannot
find it use for it so everything has the
property that it is sometimes useful so
you if your only argument for including
a feature is that it's sometime
is useful you don't even have an
argument I have a right to use every
feature okay the you know have a right
that sounds really important and good
but we've now changed the conversation
we're no longer talking about what is
the best way to write programs we're now
talking about our rights and it turns
out this argument bottoms out at do you
have the right to make crap yes I have
the right yeah I have the right it who
cares yeah it's not important that you
have the right to write crap what's much
more important is you have a
responsibility to write programs that
work well in are free of error I need
the freedom to express myself I am an
artist I am a poet and I expressed my
poetry by leaving out the semicolons I
need to reduce my keystrokes you know so
we imagine you know that we spend most
of our time typing you know what I do
today I was typing I typed a program
it's got that that's how I spend my time
but that's not actually how we spend our
time we spend most of our time staring
into the screen saying my god what have
I done that's where the time is going
but we're obsessed with trying to figure
out how to cut out as many keys as we
can if you could multiply the number of
keys by ten and cut your errors in half
that would be a good trade-off moving
keystrokes is a waste of time it is an
insult to suggest that I would make a
mistake with a dangerous feature
obviously someone who's incompetent or
less skilled less brilliant than I am
could make a mistake doing that kind of
things but it's an insult to me
personally to say that that's yeah
that's silly and there's a good reason
those features in the language and
having participated in the standards
process I can tell you for a certainty
that is not true
there are lots of reasons that things
can get into a standard and being good
is not necessarily an important one
Brendan Eich who's the guy who designed
JavaScript brilliant guy talks about
foot guns
a foot gun is a feature of a language
that you can use to shoot yourself in
the foot and he put a lot of foot guns
into JavaScript and he I think he
regrets that and would probably suggest
that we not put any more foot guns in
there but there folks who think okay
watch this I almost always miss watch so
the purpose of a programming language is
to aid programmers in producing error
free programs that's that's what it's
for
so we used to think that it was not
possible to write good programs in
JavaScript so there's no point in even
trying you just you can't do it so just
write whatever you want and that turns
out not to be true it's not only
possible to write good programs in
JavaScript it is necessary it is so easy
to go off the rails with JavaScript
there's so many invitations to write bad
code then you have to bring more
discipline to JavaScript than you would
bring to other languages so one of the
things that's confusing about javascript
is it has the same name as Java and
there are two different languages and
people are still confused about what's
the difference between Java and
JavaScript it's similar to the confusion
we have between Star Trek and Star Wars
you know two successful science fiction
franchises with spaceships and stuff and
and they both have basically the same
name but the fans know that they're not
the same that they're very different for
example in Star Trek
you've got phasers photon torpedoes
uniforms dam regulations and in Star
Wars you've got lightsabers and blasters
proton torpedoes sand and chaos so
javascript is obviously the Star Wars of
programming languages and when you're
working with JavaScript you have a
choice you can go Jedi or you can go Jar
Jar
and sadly a lot of our brothers have
decided that they want to go jar-jar so
a couple of programming patterns I've
seen are the fallible or the fantasy of
infallibility and the futility of
faultless Ness so the first one the
fantasy of infallibility I see this bone
lenient mostly in young guys who think
that they have these extraordinary
skills and they can write just really
crazy wild reckless code you know enough
that they can pull it off because
they've got such mad skills then the
futility of thoughtlessness I see more
in older guys who have seen that it
never works it's never going to work why
even try so two very different attitudes
but they both lead to the same thing
danger driven development where they'll
take unnecessary risks in writing their
code just to keep it interesting so one
of the things that makes software
difficult to manage is the difficulty of
scheduling the the first problem is how
long will it take to write a piece of
code and asking a programmer how long
that's going to take is not going to
work because we are optimists we have to
be optimists in order to do this work
and as a result of that we can't
schedule a worth crap it's just of that
you know because you know that's how
long will it take to write that code and
you won't think well it's probably about
that many keystrokes and go get it you
should be taking about that long and
because we forget about that time right
because we black that out it's just the
typing time and that turns out to be a
wildly wrong estimate but then there's
time be the time it takes to make the
code work well ideally that should be
zero right time a you write the code B
it works you're done except and that
turns out not to be the case that often
time B is huge sometimes time B is
bigger than time a
sometimes time B is infinite that's what
happens if a project is canceled after
the code is finished because they never
get it to work and that happens way too
often so if you're doing anything
cutting any corners taking any risks in
time a to make time a smaller that
increases time B you're doing it wrong
in time time a is the time to try to
force time B to go to zero you should
always take the time to code well
sometimes you're doing something that's
only gonna have to run once so go let's
just be sloppy just get it done really
fast cheap and dirty except you still
have to make it work there's no point in
writing the code if it's not going to
work and it's going to be easier to make
it work if you code it well in all cases
we should always code well so there's
some new parts in es6 es6 was proved by
the ACMA general assembly a couple of
years ago and it's now finally starting
to find its way into browsers and into
node not everything is there yet for
example my most favorite new feature of
es6 proper tail calls not there yet but
this is a brilliant thing it allows for
an optimization called continuation
passing style in which you have
functions which are always going forward
never practically returning it's a
brilliant way of doing things we'll talk
a little bit more about that in a minute
the ellipsis operator which sometimes
called rest and time sometimes called
spread which provides a much better way
of dealing with functions with a
variable number of parameters than what
we got any s5 with the arguments array
so here are two versions of the curry
function which each can take any number
of arguments in any position and that's
the way you write it in the s6 and
that's why you wrote it in es5
which one would you have to maintain
anybody mm-hmm I think it's pretty clear
I really like that one so the dot dot
dot means any number of things can go in
that position that's pretty nice
modules so one in the browser in the
original implementation of JavaScript
every code unit used global variables to
communicate with all of the other code
units and that turned out to be a really
bad pattern in node they found that to
be intolerable so they replaced it with
a crappy require system which
unfortunately is blocking and so that's
not good it's also way too complicated
so ESX provides a module system which
works asynchronously and it can give you
secure reliable module boundaries which
is what we need unfortunately the design
turned out to be way more complex than I
think it should have been but there's a
subset of the module syntax which is
just fine and so I'm very pleased that
that's becoming available we have let
and constant the language now let is the
new var that in var do essentially the
same thing except let respects block
scope and var didn't so you want to be
using one of them now and I recommend
the one you use now is let only because
it doesn't confuse the Java guys so much
the Java guys got really confused about
var but with let they'll be less
confused and I think anything we can do
to cause the Java community to be less
confused would be a really good thing oh
we've got a new D structuring syntax
which i think is pretty nice so you can
see that this let statement is a
shorthand for this one where each of
these variable names will be initialized
with a property from this object which
has the same name and it doesn't let us
do anything that we couldn't do before
but it's a nice shortcut and there are
some patterns which are nicely expressed
this way but you can go way out of hand
and do stupid stuff with that as well so
recommend you not do that then weak map
weak map doesn't fix a major problem in
JavaScript it sort of puts another thing
there so one of the design errors in
JavaScript is
that the keys of an object have to be
strings if you try to pass in an object
or something it'll try to convert it
into a string before it'll use it as a
key which is a shame because there are a
lot of applications which really want an
object in that position and we couldn't
fix it because they're programs on the
web that depend on that bad behavior so
instead of fixing it we added another
kind of object called a week map and
with a week map it's like an object
except that the keys can be other
objects and so there are classes of
functions that can only be written using
week map that cannot be written in the
language as it is and it works really
well with the garbage collector so that
if an object that's being used as a key
wants to be garbage collected it
automatically gets removed from the week
map which is really really nice the
biggest problem with week map is it has
the worst name of any feature added to a
programming language because nobody
wants to put something week in their
program but it's really good and then
we've got mega string literals which are
literals which can be many lines long so
we'll look more at those in a moment so
this is a regular expression literal
this is a regular expression literal
which matches the number of literals
that are available in es6 did anybody
guess that guessing not because these
things are virtually impossible to read
and understand which really concerns me
because we often use them for input
validation and for security filtering
but if they're longer than an inch or
two it's really hard to know what
they're actually doing so there's a
thing we can do now I've got I'm going
to make my wrapper around the regular
expression constructor and so I can pass
in a string and I'll remove all the
whitespace and then try to turn it into
a regular expression and so that lets me
write like this so up there that little
tick is the beginning of a mega string
literal and there's a little tick there
down at the bottom which closes it so
everything in between is one string
and now I can easily read the regular
expression I can see if it starts with a
zero it might be a binary or an octal or
a hex or a floating-point number this is
a much no which one you want to maintain
you know the top one that one so I think
this is much much much better but even
so I'm still not confident that I can
accurately predict what a regular
expression will do so there's a tool
available on the web called regulates or
you can give it a regular expression and
it will give you a railroad diagram so
you can see graphically what this thing
is going to match and I love that so I
will never write another regular
expression without running it through
regular x so these are some of the other
new features that we have in es6 I think
these were probably bad parts proxies
started as a well-intentioned thing that
we want to have a no such method method
so if you have a function an object and
someone calls a method that it doesn't
have instead of throwing an exception
you would like the object to be able to
handle it somehow but that turned into
this proxy thing which is really
complicated and kind of changes the
behavior of everything that kind of
scary
we have generators which are sort of a
good idea except they're completely
unnecessary if you understand how
JavaScript works you know that you can
write generators simply by having a
function that returns a function you've
got a factory that returns a generator
and each time you call that generator
you get another value and that's a
really straightforward way of doing
things in JavaScript much better than
what was actually put into es6 because
that has really weird syntax it's very
inefficient it's and it's not necessary
iterators are part of the same deal the
symbols are unnecessary because we have
week maps the things that symbols allow
you to do week maps do I think an even
better way reflection also work with
those things then we got that arrow
functions or farts and hipsters love
these
but I'm not such a fan so the idea is
that we can make a function in a much
smaller way so instead of having to type
the word function you just write a fart
and that's all you have to do
I didn't think typing function was all
that hard but so we put this in so we've
got a parameter list on one side and
we've got a an expression on the other
side so when you call the function
you'll bind an argument to that
parameter and return that result yeah
it's pretty good except for this case
this looks like it's going to construct
a little object with an ID property
except this is actually gonna return
undefined because there was an
intentional error made in the way that
this was designed and I don't know why
we keep putting this crap into this
language it's just it's got too many
things where you can write something
that looks completely reasonable that
fails in a silent way which is the worst
way you can fail so I don't recommend
using these things and until this gets
fixed I'm gonna continue writing the
word function so the worst bad part in
es6 is obviously class this was the most
requested feature in es6 it was mostly
requested by Java guys who were having
to write in JavaScript because that's
where the jobs were going but they
didn't want to have to learn it and so
by putting class in there they don't
have to learn they can just keep doing
the stuff that they were doing in Java
except it turns out that we didn't
actually add classes to JavaScript this
is just syntactic sugar on top of the
prototypal stuff that was always there
and so it doesn't work the way a Java
programmer might think it works and so
it's sort of a trap and also if you keep
stuck in this paradigm you will never
learn the object-oriented paradigm where
you can do things by having functions
that take functions as arguments and
return functions you know higher order
functions that stuff is brilliant and if
you're doing this you will never find
this out so the people writing with
we'll go to their graves never knowing
how miserable they were so I've been
thinking about what I wrote in my book
about what I considered to be good parts
and what I got right and what I got
wrong about that and so in the book I
recommended not using new using
object.create instead that's more direct
way of of setting up the prototypal
inheritance chain and I managed to get
object dr. create added to es5 just so
that I could use it so I was surprised
when I noticed that I'd stopped using
object.create because I put it in there
just for me and I don't use it so why is
that it's because of ad safe so in 2007
there were a number of research projects
that were trying to find safe subsets of
JavaScript there was FPGAs at Facebook
there was web sandbox at Microsoft there
was the caja project at Google my own ad
safe project and others and one of the
hard problems we all had to solve was
what to do about this if you have a
function and you call it as a function
this will be bound to the object of
interest and that's exactly what you
want that's a good thing but if you call
that same function as a function this
will be bound to the global object which
is a security compromise and we have to
prevent that so how do you stop that
from happening and the approach that all
the other projects took was to have
translators so they'd have a program
that would read your program and spit
out a different JavaScript program that
had lots of indirection and runtime
checking built into it to prevent this
from being down to the global object and
they all had the result of making the
code much bigger much slower much harder
to debug so I took a different approach
I said let's just make this illegal if
we see this in a program we will reject
it and we're done that's much easier and
my assumption was that if you take this
out of JavaScript
left with a functional programming
language it's still turing-complete
so you should be able to do everything
that you need to do so to test that
hypothesis I started writing in that
dialect of JavaScript and I was really
surprised to discover that it wasn't
harder it was actually easier that was
easier to write programs my programs
were smaller and better so I thought huh
that's pretty neat so I don't use this
anymore
um and I stopped using null so
javascript has to bottom values null and
undefined there is an argument in in
language design should you even have a
bottom value but there's nobody who
thinks you should have two of them in
JavaScript has two and some people use
them interchangeably but they are not
interchangeable that they behave
differently in certain circumstances so
I decided I need to get rid of one of
them and so when I decided to get rid of
was null I stopped using false eNOS I
decided that the falsie idea the bullish
value in JavaScript was a bad idea it
was intended to reproduce something that
was in C in C C is a an under typed
language so C will use the same value to
represent 0 false null and of string in
a few other things and so all the
condition of an if is concerned with is
are you zero or not and Brendan wanted
to have the same kind of idioms in his
if statements in JavaScript and I think
that was a mistake
so I stopped using false eNOS I now want
to have everything try to resolve to a
boolean as Java did I think Java got
that right I don't use for loops anymore
because the in in es5 we got these
wonderful new array methods which will
iterate over arrays so there's no really
for fors anymore
I don't use for in because I managed to
get object keys into es 5 so that now
gives you a nice array of all view
numeral enumerable own properties of an
object
so and then I can use the nice array
methods on those if six will have proper
tail calls and at that point I will stop
using loops entirely so your two
versions of the repeat statement the one
up there is using a while loop the one
down here is using tail recursion so es6
requires that when the last thing a
function does is return the result of
calling another function instead of
generating a call return sequence it
will generate a jump and so that means
that these two functions should run at
the same speed with the same memory
pressure that because this is jumping
back to the top of the function it's
reusing its current activation object so
it doesn't have to generate more stuff
we're not going to see any stack
overflows this can run as deep as we
want without any performance penalty
which is great so for a long time we've
had a performance argument for why you
shouldn't use tail recursion that goes
away so I'm really pleased about that
one of the benefits of this is that it
enables continuation passing style and
also gives us a form of go-to which is
safe so the designers of transpilers
have been asking for a go to because
they have languages which might want to
have a different set of control
structures or flows than what you can
get in the standard JavaScript set and
so they wanted to be able to emit their
own go-to so that they could have
control over that and we didn't want to
do that because we knew it would happen
if we put goto back into the language so
instead we have tail recursion or proper
tail calls which are a much better
structured higher discipline basically
it's goto with an argument list really
good stuff I've been thinking a lot
about the next language about the
language that replaces JavaScript I feel
that there's got to be a next language
because if it turns out javascript is
the last language that would be really
sad I mean the children right you don't
want to leave JavaScript to your
children that well what
and you know how would you explain that
you know so there's got to be a next
language and I've been trying to
identify it what are the signs whatever
what are its properties how will we know
when it is here the only thing I'm
certain of is that when the new language
does appear we will reject it out of
hand because we are as irrational and
emotional as normal people now this may
sound like an insult but I believe it is
true so here's my evidence
so it took a generation to agree that
high level programming languages were a
good idea the first generation of
programmers were all writing machine
language which is really really
difficult
and then Fortran and and the other first
generation of high-level languages occur
and these languages made programming so
much easier and the programmers of the
day mostly rejected them because we
cannot afford to give up this level of
control we need to be able to get down
to the metal in order to do our work we
can't afford the potential loss of
performance that we might get it took a
generation to agree that go-to was a bad
idea
Dijkstra publishes his letter in the C
ACM and that starts a really vicious
emotional argument that goes on for two
decades and then they're fighting and
fighting and fighting and the two sides
can't really hear each other and it's
just noisy and it just goes on and on it
took a generation to agree that objects
were good idea classes first occur in
Simula in Norway really really important
discovery which nobody takes any notice
of except one grad student at the
University of Utah who thinks that this
idea could be so powerful we could use
it in a programming language that
children could use to program their own
personal computers which is a really
amazing idea to have in the late 60s
that leads to a cycle of experimentation
which leads to small talk
which inspires C++ and pretty much
everything that that came after and so
the industry had to choose what it's
from its dominant object-oriented
language was going to be was going to be
small talk which was the best design
programming language in history or was
gonna be C++ and the industry as you
know went with C++ because it had the
advantage that you did not need to
understand what object-oriented
programming was in order to use it and
that decision was made by people who
didn't understand what object-oriented
programming was the C++ got some things
fundamentally wrong but every language
since then has copied those mistakes and
it took a generation to agree that
lambdas were a good idea lambdas as
functions with lexical closure with
static scoping were discovered in the
scheme language and it took two
generations for that idea to finally get
to the mainstream anybody know what
language it was that brought that idea
to the mainstream any guesses because we
see it all over the place now because it
actually solves a lot of problems that
were now experiencing the language was
JavaScript JavaScript was the first
language to do that so the reason these
things take a generation is because we
don't change minds we have to wait for a
generation of programmers to retire or
die before we can get critical mass on
the next good idea now I was there when
this happened with go-to there's this
argument that was going on and on you
can't take my gotu away from me go-to is
how I express myself I'm a go-to guy you
know there's all this performance that
we get from go-to I'm an artist
look at my go-to art just and it just
went on and on and on you can't take it
away from me I need it to do my work
it's an essential tool and and
predictions of all the terrible failures
and all the problems they're going to
happen if they took the go-to away my
cold dead hands and then one day it was
quiet
it's like are they gone can we get rid
of the go-to now yeah we got rid of
go-to and everything's great all the
predictions about all the terrible
things that we're going to happen didn't
happen it turns out that getting rid of
go-to made it easier to write programs
with greater complexity with go-to
complexity can easily get out of control
and you get spaghetti code and by going
to structured programming we could get
more complex before being overwhelmed by
the complexity so who benefits from that
the people who are arguing against it
and that's the way it is with all of
these paradigm shifts each of these is a
paradigm shift and it's really hard to
get to the next one
and I believe that the next language
will represent another paradigm shift
and that's why we will reject it so I
would sort all languages into two
categories
I think they should either be systems
languages or application languages the
dominant system language is still C
which i think is a problem because C has
been around since the 70s we know that
there were mistakes made in C we have
learned a lot since then
but we haven't replaced it yet I think
that's really a problem we seem to have
lost the ability to empty innovate in
system languages but I'm more concerned
with application languages because
that's where most of us live there's
some applications some languages that I
think make the mistake of not knowing
which side of the line they want to be
on I think the biggest design mistake in
Java was that it was trying to be both
and as a result of that confusion
threads are required in application
programs which was a huge mistake I
think that was inexcusable so I would
take application languages and I'd split
them into two categories those that do
classical inheritance which is almost
everything and those that do prototypal
inheritance which is pretty much just
JavaScript and for a long time I was an
advocate of prototypal inheritance but
um I'm not so much anymore so prototypal
inheritance definitely has advantages
over the
classical model when you're doing
classical programming you have to design
your objects and then make them into
classes you have to decide you know
that's going to be one of those and
that's gonna be one of those that's not
too hard but then you have to come up
with your taxonomy the taxonomy is where
you decide how they are all related to
each other what's going to inherit from
what what's going to implement what
what's going to interface what and it
turns out that is really hard it's
really really complicated and you're
doing it at the point of the project at
the beginning when you have the least
understanding of how it's going to work
and so inevitably you get it wrong you
you just get it wrong because you don't
know yet what the correct solution is
and as you work you start noticing how
it's wrong that things don't compose the
way you want them to compose that you
start wishing that you had multiple
inheritance because you just can't get
these things to fit right and as you
start layering more more classes on top
of it you find that that breakage is
seeping up into all of the levels and
eventually it may get so bad that you
decide we need to refactor which is
really scary because that means you're
going to tear all the code apart and you
don't want to do that because it might
not ever come back together again and in
the prototypal model that doesn't happen
and I tell this story to people who do
the classical stuff and go wow that's
really interesting except you're still
gonna have to refactor sometime right no
you don't have to do that go well but
you're still gonna refactor right I mean
just no no so the principle advantage we
get from the prototypal model versus
something that just copies functions
from one object to another is memory
conservation that using object dot
create instead of object assign the
value we get is memory conservation
which is something that made sense in
1995 but since then Moore's Law has been
so incredibly generous on every capacity
that that's not a reasonable trade-off
anymore you now have literally gigabytes
of RAM in your pocket right now
you just cannot imagine
how much memory you're walking around
with so trying to shave bits off of an
object just it's in the noise it doesn't
matter anymore when's the last time you
saw a browser given out of memory error
it just doesn't happen
there are now two kinds of properties
their own properties and inherited
properties which sometimes work exactly
the same but sometimes work differently
whenever you have things which are
almost the same but different that's a
source of confusion and confusion leads
to bugs we get retroactive heredity so
what an object inherits can change after
it's constructed which I've not found
any good uses for that but I've seen
very bad uses of that one of them is
that it is performance inhibiting so
modern JavaScript engines go very fast
by making assumptions about the shapes
of objects but they have to be
pessimistic about prototype chains
because they cannot see when the things
in the chain are being modified so I'm
no longer an advocate of prototypal
inheritance an advocate of class free
object-oriented programming
I think class free object-oriented
programming is JavaScript's gift to
humanity so here's how I think it should
work so we'll start with the idea of
block scope I assume that everybody's
familiar with block scope we've got two
blocks in each block we can create
variables but the variables are only
visible in the inner blocks they're not
visible to the outer blocks but the
inner block can see the variables of the
outer blocks and we can do the same
thing with functions because a function
is just a block with some extra plumbing
around it which allows it to be executed
in the future and so we've got the same
relationship and we can express that
relationship as a Venn diagram so this
is the set of the variables that the
outer function can see and this is the
set of variables that the inner function
can see and we can see that the inner
function encloses the set of the outer
function and that's why we call this
closure
I think it's unfortunately we call it
closure because at least an English
closure is very overloaded some people
think it means retribution or vengeance
and we're just saying one set closes
over the other set so it took a long
time for this idea to get to the
mainstream because of this case now
suppose the inner functions survives the
execution of the outer function which
would happen if we return it so the
inner function wants to have access to a
so when the green function is called a
is put onto the stack it returns the
yellow function and then we'll call the
yellow function yellow function wants to
go to a but a is no longer on the stack
so boom and it took us like 40 years to
figure out how to fix this it turns out
the solution is trivial that you don't
allocate on the stack you allocate on a
heap and you know with the garbage
collector you just clean it all up and
this is what javascript figured out
which and now all of the languages are
trying to do this even Java and this is
such a powerful pattern that having a
function that returns a function
higher-order functions there is so much
power so much expressive power in this
this is how we should be writing
programs so this is how I recommend
making objects in a class free way so
I've got a constructor function
I recommend passing in a specification
object you could still pass in the
individual parameters if you want to but
I think this is a more powerful way to
do it you could because you can just put
an object literal inside the call to the
constructor and that essentially lets
you have named properties so you can
have the properties in any order some
years ago I wrote a constructor that had
ten arguments in it which was a problem
because nobody could remember what order
they went in and after a while we
discovered that nobody used the third
argument but we couldn't take it out
because that would have broken all the
code so if I had been smart I would have
just passed in an object and then
missing arguments we could fill in
reasonable defaults extra arguments we
could just ignore and again the order
wouldn't matter
so I would use that to create my member
variables this again is using the
destructuring syntax so I can name as
many member variables as I want and
initialize them with properties of the
object that have the same value then I
can't if I need to I can call other
constructors passing in the same
specification object because we'll be
using the union of all of the
specifications that's what the user will
will pass in and they'll make something
and pass it back and we will extract
from it just the methods that we need
this is a solution to the banana problem
if you heard about the banana problem
you want to inherit a banana but you end
up also inheriting the gorilla who's
holding the banana and all of the rest
of the jungle just wanted the banana
well now you can say banana and you'll
just get the banana and because we're
copying the methods out you can call as
many of these as you want so we can have
a compositional form where we'll call
other things and get all of the stuff
that will make our object better and
just incorporate it into our own local
variables then we'll create our own
methods and because of closure our own
methods will have access to all of that
goodness without using this and then we
will have an outgoing object will where
we'll simply list the new public methods
and we'll freeze the object so now the
object will be immutable incorruptible
in confusable you know an object of high
integrity that we can use to build
secure reliable systems so when we
started doing object-oriented sort of
starts with Pascal records we've got a
simple data type with named fields in it
and we have a name which gets us to a
value and we extend that idea by saying
the names can also represent methods or
functions that will act on those values
and that was a an important step forward
but it should not have been the last
stop because it leads to a style
programming where you're focused on the
individual properties and not on the
whole and so it's hard for the whole to
have integrity when you allow access to
the individual members so what I
recommend instead is that we raise the
level of the interface more in terms of
actions and less in terms of the
specific data items so that they'll now
be two distinct types of objects
there will be objects containing just
data one shall be collections of values
which we can pass around as parameters
to objects and there'll be objects that
contain only methods which will act on
those objects the immutable data will be
held in variables in the constructor
function and I think that's how we
should be writing stuff so I need to
confess I made a bug in 2001 and it's
really been bothering me I need to tell
you about it so I wrote a jsonparser in
Java to show how easy it was to write
JSON parsers had it included this
declaration of a variable called index
that was an INT and that was intended to
count the number of character positions
you were in to a string or a stream in
case there was a syntax er than it could
report at what position the error
occurred and a int is pretty big that'll
get you to about 2 billion and at the
time I'd never made a JSON object that
was bigger than a couple of K's so I
thought this is future proof this is
going to work fine until a few years ago
I got a bug report from someone who
found who was trying to parse a JSON
text that was several gigabytes in size
and there was a syntax error past two
and they got a wildly wrong error
message goes negative and that they were
very smart and they very quickly
recognized what I got wrong and it was
because of this int thing I
intz I think intz are the one of the
worst things we've done to ourselves and
programming and the problem with them is
overflow now what happens if inte
overflows they do the worst possible
thing you throw away all the most
important significance and there's no
rapport and so it's really hard to have
integrity in your application if you
have a number system that can go wildly
wrong without notification so why did
this happen it's because it made sense
in the 50s in the 50s we were making
computers out of vacuum tubes vacuum
vacuum tubes are big and there are hot
they draw a lot of power they burn out
really quickly and so if you can figure
out a way to reduce the number of tubes
in your design and that's really good
and some genius I believe he was a
genius figured out that if we use
complement arithmetic then we don't need
to build a subtract circuit we just
complement before add and ignore the
overflow and that was so much easier and
we're still doing that it's not that 50s
anymore but that's how our system still
work also memory used to be really
expensive and scarce I don't know if
anyone remembers the Atari 2600 VCS that
machine had a hundred 28 bytes of RAM in
it 128 bytes so the guys that program
that machine were heroes they had to
figure out how to make a video game work
in 128 bytes and so they would want to
use memory really really carefully but
today you've got gigabytes in your
pocket it's a different world so when
you're programming and byte in Java
every time you create a new variable or
property or parameter you have to ask
byte char short and long float or double
which one you have to pick one of those
and if you get it right then the program
will work and if you get it wrong the
program is eventually going to fail but
it will probably not fail in your tests
because your tests assume
the test that the types are right but
your type is wrong and tests don't find
those sorts of type errors you expect
the compiler to find them but the
compiler is not finding it and there's
no benefit from choosing the right one
the the reason Java gave you all those
choices was again because a long time
ago there wasn't much memory but trying
to shave bits off of a variable now is a
complete waste of time
javascript on the other hand has only
one number type that means you don't
waste any time trying to decide what the
type of a number is and you cannot make
a mistake by choosing the wrong number
type which is good in that way
javascript is strictly superior to Java
and most of the other languages the only
problem is it's the wrong type and the
reason it's the wrong type is because of
this there are some people who think
this is okay I think this is not okay
Java scripts problem is it's using the I
Triple E 754 floating point standard
which is a binary floating-point
standard which cannot accurately
represent the decimal fractions which is
only a problem if you're on a planet
that uses a decimal system but we are
and so it doesn't work so it's binary
floating-point so why are we using
binary floating-point because it made
sense in the 50s again so in the 40s
when the first 1 million machines start
coming online there are integer only
machines but they were built and used by
mathematicians who want to be doing math
on the real numbers so they start by
doing scaled arithmetic which is really
difficult and someone figures out we can
do floating-point we can represent a
number as two numbers one is the
collection of digits and the other is
where the decimal point is and they
could have libraries which would let you
add and subtract and multiply and divide
using that representation which made
programming much easier and much more
accurate but it was really slow so when
machines start to become mass-produced
there's interest in putting that into
hardware but the problem is intestinal
floating-point in order to
just numbers you have to be able to
divide by 10 and dividing by 10 with
vacuum tubes is really hard so some
genius thought if we change the basis
from 10 to 2 we only have to do a shift
and we can do shifts for free so it's
like brilliant we'll do that
and we're still doing it now the
business programmers at the time said we
cannot use that you cannot represent
money and we have to add up the money
correctly or people go to jail so we're
not going to do that so they came up
with their own system and called BCD
binary coded decimal so when you ordered
your mainframe you would either get the
floating-point package and run Fortran
or you get the BCD package and run COBOL
and so it was sort of two worlds but
then computing kind of grew up and
swallowed everything COBOL disappeared
and Java became the successor to COBOL
but Java is a child of Fortran and not
COBOL so it gets the numbers wrong and
everybody's been getting the numbers
wrong ever since so I proposed to fix it
and my solution is called Dec 64 where I
have a 64 bit quantity which represents
numbers and it's very much like the
representation that was used in the 40s
the coefficient is a 56 bit number which
can contain sixteen point three digits
approximately and the exponent is eight
bits so that gets us over 100 in either
direction which i think is enough for
most applications and the value of a
number is simply the coefficient times
tend to the exponent so it's that's all
of the encoding it's really simple so
you can take any existing int shift at
eight bits it's now at deck 64 in a
hardware implementation numbers with the
same exponent which would include all of
the integers every integer will have an
exponent of zero they will add in one
cycle which will completely eliminate
the need for intz because intz will no
longer give a performance advantage over
floating-point these will do those
numbers very very fast and because it's
a decimal
representation it can exactly represent
all of the numbers that are important to
humanity which is something that binary
floating-point cannot do there's a
software implementation of it available
for the x64 or M the 64 series and I
might hope for this is that this will be
the one number type in all future
application languages now it may seem an
audacious thing to say I'm going to try
to convince everybody in the world to
change their number types but it turns
out I don't have to convince everybody
in the world I only have to convince one
person and that's the man or the woman
who designs the next language if I can
convince that genius that they want to
make a language which represents numbers
the same way that humans think about
numbers in order to reduce confusions
that we can make fewer mistakes then
this is the way to go now it turns out I
have some experience at convincing
everybody in the world to do the right
thing for example there's the json data
interchange format this is Google Trends
showing XML versus Jason and he can see
that the world has steadily been losing
interest in XML since 2004 and Jason's
been very very quietly creeping up and
again there's no Jason industry nobody
is making money on Jason and except for
the people are using Jason and you know
in Google shows that finally Jason
becomes more interesting than XML this
is a more recent snapshot you can see
that it's going and today a snapshot you
know Jason's just up there and you did
that and the reason this happened was
there was no paradigm shift necessary
because in 2005 when suddenly the web
became interesting again there were a
lot of people who came in to the web to
start using javascript and they were
told you have to use XML and you very
quickly decided that's too hard let's
use this other thing instead and so we
didn't have to wait for a generation to
die because a new generation came into
the market so I didn't intend for Jason
to be the
data interchange format it's really good
for the thing that was designed to do
which was to allow programs written in
different languages to communicate data
back and forth and it does that really
well but um it's being used for other
things and for some of those
applications it's not ideal so it may be
that other data formats should be
invented so if anyone here is thinking
of creating one of those let me give you
some advice first is please don't break
Jason Jay the best thing I did in Jason
Jason is not perfect but the best thing
I did was I did not put a version number
on it so there is no way of changing it
without breaking it so please don't try
to break it don't try to amend the jason
standard to add some new stuff make a
new standard and make it better i
recommend don't just make it better make
it significantly better
don't just be jason with one little
thing on it because if you have
something which is jason like but not
quite jason then you're adding a
confusion tax which can turn into errors
and be a problem for people so if you're
going to do that add enough of value to
it to justify that cost and please give
it a better name because the worst thing
about jason for sure is the name for one
thing nobody knows how to pronounce it I
say Jason most people say Jason it turns
out that correct pronunciation is real
soul everybody I've seen people take
Jason and put a letter in front of it or
a letter behind it or a number or
something don't do that give it a
completely different name because the
names not good so it stands for
JavaScript object notation which means
well so I that name itself is confusing
so having JavaScript in there well
there's already confusion about what is
JavaScript and you know that Java is at
what
and then having JavaScript in the name
it suggests that the JavaScript standard
is what defines what Jason is or it only
works with JavaScript and none of that's
true there's a Jason standard which is
what Jason is so I put the word
JavaScript in there to give recognition
to JavaScript you know because it
existed in nature I didn't invent Jason
I just identified it as already a
feature of JavaScript and suggested it
could be used independently so I was
trying to give JavaScript credit but it
wasn't like I was trying to get on
JavaScript coattails because at the time
javascript was the most hated language
in the world so you know yeah we're
we're part of that that wasn't getting
us much love then the idea of object
here is JavaScript's idea of object
which i think is a good one of a
collection of properties the casual
thing whereas in most of the other
languages that's not what an object is
an object is an instance of a class and
it's a very rigid thing so people in
those languages get confused why are
they calling this thing an object
notation is okay I can't find any
problems with the word notation so if
you want to use that that's fine so
finally I want to talk about
responsibility and this is my personal
view Who am I responsible to when I'm
writing a program my number one
responsibility is to the people to the
poor bastards you're gonna have to use
my software I want it to be really good
for them I don't want it to to error out
I don't want it to fail I don't want to
be slow I don't want to frustrate them I
don't want to damage their lives and I
want to hurt them in any way I want them
to benefit for using my software I want
to be good now I've seen programming
teams who hate their users who think
those people are stupid they're the
source of all our misery if they don't
understand how to use our stuff they ask
for new features that don't make any
sense they do not appreciate our genius
we hate them that is a terrible attitude
as completely toxic unacceptable we
should never ever
do that everything we do should be in
service to humanity we have this idea in
our profession that we are making the
world a better place
ignoring all of the evidence that shows
that we're not but I want to at least
make it better for the people who are
using my software when they are using my
software the number two is the team I
want to write good stuff for the team so
that someone else on my team can take my
code and make it better I don't want to
be putting traps or hazards or
confusions into my code which are likely
to make my team members fail including
team members who we haven't hired yet
who I haven't met yet including future
me that future me may may not remember
why I did the things that I did had
struggled to maintain my own code word
our software has gotten so complex that
it's now a team effort that it used to
be one person could write an operating
system I don't think that's likely to
ever happen again so we have teams
building stuff and it's similar to team
literature you know if you have a team
that's writing a magazine or writing an
encyclopedia you would like to have
everybody on that writing team write
with the same voice so to a reader it
looks like this was written by one
writer and that in no way restricts the
creativity of the writers because the
important thing is not how you use your
punctuation but how clearly you express
your ideas and having a house style does
not restrict that in any way that's the
way you display genius so I on my team I
want everybody on the team to be writing
in the style of the best most
professional programmer who ever lived
I want everybody to be writing at that
level I don't want anybody coming down
the code because they need to express
themselves then number three management
if management asks for it it makes sense
okay we'll do that too
now some managers will go oh wait a
minute
we're supposed to be in charge here
shouldn't we be number one and I think
no I think I got this right so one of
the most important jobs of the CEO or
president is to focus the company on the
outside there's a tendency particularly
in large companies everything becomes
inward focused we're all about our own
process competition for our own
resources and the CEO kind of turns
everybody around and will say things
like be the customer be a customer
champion everybody is doing customer
service they're turning people outward
we need to be aware and serving the
people on the outside because that's
what we're all about and so you know
that's the people and number two there's
a tendency in companies that the
software is not an asset it becomes a
liability that there's so much crap and
clutter in the code that it is the
reason why we can't compete effectively
in the marketplace we've got a new idea
that we could implement it software but
it means we have to get the old stuff to
work and it's just really really hard it
slows everything down but if we wrote
everything for the team at that level of
quality then the software is not a
liability it is an asset and we can go
to market much faster so before we go I
just want to leave you with one piece of
advice I'm really serious about this
please do not make bugs thank you
[Applause]